welcome back everybody
how you doing good how are you I love
that right before we're gonna start you
look at what I'm wearing to decide if
you should make a joke that's all just
know I did what you're wearing but it's
funny you're right it looked exactly at
it what I was really thinking was you
wore a grayish sweatshirt yesterday or
Monday Monday and I give took a double
look just see if it was that same God
forbid I wear the same clothes well
because you also wore the same clothes
today as you were yesterday what do you
mean didn't you wear that hoodie with
your roses on it yeah yesterday no show
no I wear that for sure I wear that
today today okay I saw just really
paying attention because my fashionista
people look for you for inspiration I
get it I know you've been trying to Jack
my style
no more crewneck look I know that you've
always liked admire the way I button my
top button I want to go back to
something we started with on Mondays
podcast Atlanta Atlanta Atlanta Atlanta
a little update to what we're doing
first of all thank you to the dozens of
people that are already reserving space
we just want to tell everybody like it's
we don't have unlimited space so it's it
might get a little bit tight but we're
gonna be at Dan Tana's and the CNN
center right near the stadium where the
Super Bowl be played the week of the
Super Bowl near radio row the hotels
bars the NFL experience Tuesday 5
o'clock podcast Wednesday 5:00 o'clock
podcast Thursday 6 p.m. show Friday 4:30
pock holy crap you're signed up for all
those I am are we sure are you gonna
check Mike I call my agent because I
don't know if I'm supposed to work that
much if you're coming email Sims and
Lefko at gmail.com Sims and Lefko at
gmail.com to all of the dozens of people
that have already emailed Josh you guys
are awesome he's going to respond back
to you with a sign-up link to get your
name on the list
we're gonna have some wristbands and
also there's a chance there's going to
be free drinks so get your 19:42 ready
they won't have that why not because
it's like so so ok if we're giving out
free 19:42 that
I have been being I've been underpaid
here I'm just gonna say that it's
couldn't make it for a very fun
atmosphere yeah yeah you know I mean if
we're if the drinks are flowing and
we're just shooting the [ __ ] talking
about the Super Bowl that's like three
days away in Atlanta it's gonna be a fun
night it will be get your tickets now
they're hot don't let him get the
StubHub these tickets because then
there's just they're gonna mark up the
prices for them real I'm gonna be out
front like a like a Uzi
hey come on by I got tickets it's your
love go no but it's it's it's we've
never done anything like this it's gonna
be a great time I think we've had like
70 or 80 people already kind of email
for tickets so like just letting you
guys know that Thursday the show like
the rest of the time it's gonna be
people standing and hanging out and bar
tops and all that but the Thursday show
there's really only 20 seats and that's
when we're gonna have like why just a
Thursday show because that's our show oh
it's gonna be like a show audience yeah
we're gonna break down all of your film
I've gone through all of your notes it's
changing the way that I'm looking
already at the divisional game and it a
lot of people are asking me who are you
gonna pick and I tell them I don't think
you guys think you guys understand I
farm your brain yes some of your
thoughts are going oh that's interesting
and then some I go he's gonna think this
is gonna be too big of a deal and I
don't think it will be so it impacts the
way I do my picks it should impact the
way you do your picks right but we got
to get through this coaching stuff yeah
okay we get done our podcast Monday and
our favorite quarterback that we've ever
seen Aaron Rodgers yeah has a new coach
and I was upset because I wanted to talk
about it yeah Packers hire Matt Lafleur
they want to get a young guy in there to
work alongside Aaron Rodgers that can
challenge him creatively and I
understand it but there's one name that
comes to mind when I hear this and
that's Vance Joseph Vance Joseph was the
young interesting defensive mind that
had the twenty seventh ranked pass
defense for the dollar was twenty ninth
overall rank defense and yet he still
got hired by Denver right and that's
what it feels like here yeah it's the
young up-and-coming mind that went
shoulder to shoulder with McVeigh and
Shanahan who had like the 27th best
passing offense right
and now he's the coach at Green Bay and
I'm still a little down about it I get
it and this alright this time where I'm
gonna start with this because I think
this is where people think just because
you worked with that coach you know
everything they know and I'm just gonna
say this right off the bat that's not
the case it's just like we talked about
what I thought you asked me are people
go why haven't Bill Belichick coaching
tree succeeded because bill doesn't let
him know every secret in the world
Kyle Shanahan's not gonna open the vault
be a guy with him just shot in the gym
right you don't know every decision he
exactly right McDaniel's when it was
game planning time he locked himself in
a closet and we didn't see him for seven
hours so to assume the quarterbacks
coach has all the knowledge that he has
why is wild exactly right so no you know
I've always said you learn more from bad
bosses than good boss yes I know you go
to Belichick and you're not gonna learn
a lot you're gonna have stories right
but you're gonna go and you're gonna
work under vans Joseph and you're gonna
go when I become a head coach I'm
definitely not talking to the team like
that doing that right right so and again
a lot of these coaches they're half
politician too and they realize this
they don't want the guy that leaves
their coaching tree to get a job in
their division and then also damn he's
as good as me and he knows every trick
of my offense and we're losing to them
twice a year so you got to think of that
aspect
either way back to the point yes I'm
with you I was disappointed about
Lafleur I believe that Lafleur can
become a head coach yes but he needs
more seasoning he had all he has all the
potential to be that guy but we're just
we're jump work we're hoping he's gonna
be that guy right now and again I would
remind everybody you know Shaun McVeigh
had three years of designing a Redskins
offense and it being one of the top 10
offenses in football all three years I
think one of the years it was like 16 or
17 but okay
so he did everything Kyle Shanahan we've
talked about had two top five offenses
in Houston DC he went there had some top
offenses had two top ten offenses in
Atlanta then finally got a head coaching
job
Leflore is still at the early stages and
I guess I would have liked to have seen
him being an OC and to your point I
would say and I don't like to say this
because I like Matt
and I see the potential but I mean I'm
paid to evaluate and if I had a point at
the number one weakness to the Tennessee
Titan football team it would have been
their past offense you know and I know
he's still finding his way and he's
learning players and the way my grayble
wants to play as well so I'm not putting
it all on mammal I'm also gonna add yes
to defending of him he did not have a
ton of depth behind Corey Davis no we
did not need all line issues to be they
had a lot of o line issues maybe if you
were one of the first people to get on
before the year you know looked at
interior parts very overrated right they
also lost a Lainey Walker who I can
imagine he built a lot of that offense
around in the offseason I agree but it
was the it was the lack of formations
and creativity tackling that jumped out
to me every way exactly right because I
thought this was gonna be because he
remember the preseason he had that one
screen where Tijuana Taylor took it to
the house and everybody was like the
Shanahan offense is alive in tennis yes
yeah didn't happen just not ready yet so
you know again I'm rooting for Matt
Lafleur one because I like him too
because I love Aaron Rodgers and I want
it to work but yeah this is a roll of
the dice this is a hope higher what I
would call it we hope he's everything he
can be and grow into that person but
before I do just through the years of
coddling stuff yeah what car does it
carry himself he's like um very
professional easy to talk to is he cool
he is cool he would be again what I say
somebody has head coaching potential
that's what I mean
charisma demeanor can lead people if
he's standing in front of a team yes is
he gonna command respect well when they
first look at him and I'm sure this goes
for Shaun McMahan's [ __ ] you look at
them and he go damn he's young what the
hell is he know but then once they start
to talk ball you go whoa because that's
the thing that I've heard in so many
articles as Aaron Rodgers requires an
intellect yeah that if he thinks that
you're smart you can have his respect
and I get it right do you think Lafleur
is creative enough and intelligent
enough to invigorate Aaron rod I do I do
think that success I do think he can yes
spark that and I do think Lafleur's also
opened a conversation to he's not an
evil
dictator where he's just make this is
the way and this is the way I was taught
it and we're never changing I kill this
an Aaron Rodgers an Arab like you know
I'd like to tinker with this on this
concept or whatever yeah okay I'm guess
he's gonna respect that Aaron Rodgers
studies the game and knows it as well
so I do think the working relationship
would be there but I just like I said in
the perfect world I would have liked to
see lap Matt Lafleur prove himself a
little bit more as an OSI find different
ways to execute call plays formulate
plans that's where I feel like he's
still at a kind of a beginner phase of
his career so another team decided to go
on social media and see who else is Sean
McVeigh friends with on Facebook we'd
like to hire them and that's what the
Cardinals did I'm friends with these
guys yeah when are you gonna come on is
that all I had to do is just hire a
circle are you friends with McVeigh or
Shannon Cardinals hire Kliff Kingsbury
yeah this is even more shocking than the
Green Bay hire yes and I'm gonna say one
sentence and I'm not gonna give you my
opinion
Kliff Kingsbury had a losing record with
Patrick mahomes in the big 12 yeah all
I'm gonna say
you didn't win with Patrick mahomes I
wasn't sure if he really want to Baker
Mayfield as a starting quarterback cuz
it's really funny as people go winds are
in a stat it is with coaching yeah it is
with coaching it definitely is are you
shocked by this it sounds like it was a
rush job too shocked like beyond belief
I think he's shocked he doesn't take the
USC offensive coordinator job if he
knows he's got a chance to be the head
coach in the NFL he would have never
done that so he had no Inklings about
that I think it was early December when
he accepted the USC job right so um
again I'm gonna use a similar phrase I
just used him that before I know Kliff
Kingsbury same thing I'm gonna tell you
he has the potential and all the
characteristics to be a successful hog
head coach you've actually covered him
as a coach right exactly roan Baker
Mayfield was his starting quarterback
and they couldn't figure out whether
they wanted to play Baker Mayfield or
Davis Webb I'm on a game at Kansas the
Jayhawks going you know hey this Davis
Webb he's a good looking athlete but
Baker may feel is the guy I mean go back
and watch it I don't know what
Russell will side was yeah even this is
even before I got into that yet but I
was going man this Baker may feel he's
pretty damn good player but okay so
first of all you're not a quarterback
genius just because you can recruit guys
to come to your school okay I mean
there's nothing to do with coaching or
doing anything but Kingsbury does have
potential he is a leader of men
again great charisma people skills
there's no nonsense nonsense with cliff
and again another guy that I looked at
and said damn yeah he has big-time
potential to be a star NFL head coach
one day but not this route now he's
risking how successful he can be and I
don't blame him because I would probably
take the job as well but would love to
have seen him go work for a Sean McVeigh
or an Andy Reid for a few years and grow
his diversity of his playbook I will go
into like something I've said about Mike
McCarthy or Aaron Rodgers in their
offense he doesn't even know what he
doesn't know yet let go that's what I
was gonna say about Lafleur and then I
would double it with Kings right sure
sure I would double it for sure and
again I would always be skeptical about
guys who really just grew in the college
ranks right I'm gonna always throw these
two examples out there the college
college football is a different game
it's way more simple you know NFL
football is trigonometry and college
football's fourth and fifth grade math
that's the best way I could say it okay
it's just totally different games
defense's players wise the coaches
you're coaching against you know he put
coach in the big 12 and he saw the same
three coverages the whole year against
you know talent on the defensive side of
the ball in the big 12 which is
definitely underwhelming right we don't
see a lot of big 12 guys drafted you
don't even formulate game plans to go oh
we have to worry about this defensive
end or this you know this defense at
tackle is not even that like specific
like man-to-man matchup so that's where
I get concerned and what do you think
these guys what do you think Kliff
Kingsbury said in the interview well I
think he but how do you think you sold
himself well I'd be as no experience he
has no he has no statistics that prove
how great he is I know is they could
just go you were at Texas Tech in the
big 12 so all of your numbers are like
fake you couldn't get another head
coaching job
how did cliff sell this well he
you from all the reasons I tell you he
has the potential to be that great head
coach these are the things that come in
handy to sell it you know you get in a
room with there you go damn he's
handsome he looks good up at that podium
looking I know but they do they do okay
and then they go I try to remind people
all the time yeah just because they're
billion-dollar companies does not mean
there's me exactly right a lot of them
are just because they got a fancy
business we're all trying to cover their
ass and make a big splash and and yeah
anyway we're even saying what I was just
saying like yeah I mean he he dazzles
them with his charisma and his ability
to command a room and do all of that and
again I've seen a shitty TED talk well
okay that's because you can get up there
and be good doesn't mean you say
anything exactly right but that's that's
the point what the hell does the owner
know anyways I mean now Michael Bidwell
is especially the bid will come on and
that is he that is an owner that if
you're gonna hustle you can hustle
so that okay and I would even argue GM's
GM's are great player evaluators they
don't know scheme I've sat and been with
GM's and front office bears Bennett if
there's been a team that's had a weird
time of drafting for scheme I'd say
Arizona's picked some really
questionable players over the last few
years they definitely have so you know
again I don't think the GM and the owner
could watch film a Texas second big oh
well yeah look at him run flanker drive
here guys he's really got that zebra
option play away down so I just go I go
to that and I go again with the college
football thing before you go on again I
will remind everybody Steve Spurrier was
a college offensive genius Chip Kelly
was a college offensive genius and once
these guys get to see you once or twice
it's over I could still remember hold on
the Ravens offensive system lasted eight
days exact where it was solved eight
games yeah like our g3 system worked for
like eight games and then it was like we
need to adjust I can remember the Eagles
going to scrimmage against the New
England Patriots I believe it was Chip
Kelly's second year right yes and
talking to people up in New England gone
I don't get it oh I'll get it what's
what's what's everybody looking at it
it's to run plays and a nine pass plays
that's the whole offense you know and
New England's can you be arrogant that
way how did they not get stopped by
there Eric
their honesty exactly and I'm okay with
it I am too exactly right I am too I
realized one thing the reason you will
not get the job two reasons not a strong
enough jaw that's a trend I'm seeing
right now and you don't own any scruff
no scar all these coaches got the scrub
they're all looking like Ryan Gosling
why do you think by the way you know
what this is an incidental playoff beard
ooh I've realized before the the Bears
game no no no no the Washington game I
didn't shave and I'm kind of on like a
week and a half two weeks wow that's
that's it that's all you grew no we can
have two weeks I feel like I could get a
haircut on my shoulders the other thing
is I this is what I don't understand
about society Sean McVeigh is an outlier
right that's all I hear he's a 32 year
old wunderkind and then I hear people go
I want to find my 32 year old wunderkind
wunderkind is a special person you're a
boy genius and and we understand how
rare it is and yet they still go out and
try and find the other ones right the
moral of the story is sorry you missed
out on the rare opportunity right this
isn't the norm it's an outlier and they
acknowledge how rare it is and they
still believe there's another person out
there to hire they're speaking out of
both sides of their mouth yes they are
well again it goes back to me there's a
lot of politicians in the NFL the true
football people in NFL it's like the
number one phrase I hear for them all
the time it's no longer about what you
know about the sport it's a position of
elect it's who you know that's really
what it's becoming it really frustrates
the old-school football people in the
NFL because you know they just see these
young whippersnapper he's good in a
meeting and could talk the owners it's
like it's like going hey I'm hiring this
random middle middle management guy at
Google but he was at Google so he's
gonna be really smart it's like well
what was he responsible for there yeah
what did he do yeah what did he do III
get that and listen it's just it's just
like this this elbow rubbing no it's
ridiculousness I I'll say this again I'm
just saying I'm concerned about the
hires I do know Lou because if I hunt if
I'm gonna self Scout yeah you
you thought shall McVeigh needed more
seasoning - I did I know no question
we're gonna self Scout but I'd like to
done one more year and I've told you
he's been awesome so and if the floor
and Kingsbury do awesome trust me I'll
be there to tell you the truth that
they're doing awesome I just don't think
people appreciate enough what Shawn
McVeigh did for Kirk Cousins and that
last exactly when they went to the
playoffs
Shawn McVeigh's offense was like the
number one passing attack in the NFL for
most of that season right and it's
forgotten yeah let's get to some old
guys cut the job because we're old guys
we love old girls gasps Broncos hire Vic
Fangio yeah and the first thing I
thought was Von Miller let's go yeah
yeah Bradlee chub it's it's a team that
he can do what he wants to do there they
pass up Mike Munchak which we were
rooting for both those guys I'm the
happy Fangio gets opportunity yeah it's
been a long time coming he is a little
bit he now he's a lot older than Kyle
Shanahan but he was the guy in San
Francisco had a top-ten defense every
year goes to Chicago top-10 defense
every year and we're just going why is
he not getting the opportunity right and
I like that like I said he's not a
politician Elway is gonna bounce back
young guy doesn't work now we're gonna
go old guy goes Vic Fangio and Gary
Kubiak is his OC yeah I'm not thrilled
about if that's not you know but it's
just a weird friendship well I mean
obviously he Elway has wanted Kubiak
back in the fold I do know that and I
understand well good listen we could say
all we want about Kubiak I get it I was
never overly impressed with his offense
you know that back to the Peyton Manning
year and all that it was it was
unimpressive it's basic West Coast
so here's verse can be winning games
1412 so one thing I'll give Kubiak
credit for it I don't think he gets
credit for is he made the Broncos
tougher he did he gave them an attitude
and an edge that they did not have under
John Fox and then when he took over even
though it might not have looked as
pretty as the Adam GaSe offense they
were more of a gritty playoff will
figure out a way to win this game
yeah type of team do you like Fangio as
a fit in Denver just has a personality
and all that I do because Denver is a
tough place to coach you talk about
being under under a microscope I mean it
could be it could be literally like July
in the collar
Rockies are on a forty game winning
streak and they'll be like the third
stringer for the Broncos today yeah I
mean they don't even seriously they were
talking to their psyche they're talking
about Chad Kelly all summer exactly
that's the way they are so you are but
Vick is old-school like he said last
week they asked him about are you
preparing for the head coaching
vacancies he goes I haven't spent one
second on it I'm worried about the
Eagles I love that Khalil Matt came out
and said he's an evil genius and that
other members of the Bears are saying
he's a gangsta he's like a godfather
mob's
that's what I would say he is a little
bit he is he's got that add to Bri he
looks at you and he gives you some weird
looks like a few times I've been around
him he's like gave me the willies
everything I don't think it likes me
yeah that's awesome
Buccaneers they do it they pull the
trigger and they hire Bruce Arians who
as you said before we started the show
is going we're all in on Jameis the
buddy-cop of Bruce Arians and Jameis
where Jameis has already over the moon
cocky and all Aryans does is give his
quarterbacks cockiness Byron Leftwich is
going to be the offensive coordinator
the whole band's getting back together
and as of report as of recording this
podcast
it looks like Todd Bowles will be the DC
it's not finalized yet but the reason I
think it is is Aryans has already come
out and said Bowles has wanted to come
and he's like a son to me so you get the
old Arizona coaching staff bowls now
with the defensive coordinator I love
this team I do too I love this team
they're a team this is a you know I know
we've said it but this is a this is a
secretly good job as long as you were
comfortable with the Jameis Winston
situation which he is you know he'll be
tough on Jameis but yet also let him
know that I'm in this with you this is
you and me together that's what he does
that's why these like Peyton and
Roethlisberger they all love I'm worried
about him in that humidity
oh yeah he's gonna be flush he's Bruce
Collins is gonna be sweating profusely
every game yes he will be Kobe gets
cocky and starts really wearing like
crazy clothes Oh what I think that's
where it is a great hire because I do
think the Tampa Bay fan base it will
love LA Bruce Arians
little grown-ass he's gonna dominate the
press conferences he's gonna say witty
things he's gonna say in-your-face type
of things that not everybody might like
or you know might not be or might dance
on the edge of politically correct or
whatever it may be he's a real dude
I don't know him that well I only know
people's stories from people I know but
yes I think that that Tampa fanbase will
really rally around him I think I would
think that's part of why they wanted him
because they do have trouble selling
seats there and you know they've had
success with a personality driven head
coach exactly right so I so but also
it's you look at all the weapons they've
gotten on that offense uh-huh and you
know it's been disappointing if they had
like spurts with monk in the beginning
of the year with Fitzpatrick but if
Ariens is a downfield passing attack and
that's Sheamus is strength it definitely
is a strength and listen
Dirk cutters offense is a down field
throwing offense to I mean ok they're
there that's what they do
but Ariens is going to bring a different
style and cockiness of the football team
I mean hey the Buccaneers we're the 3rd
ranked offense in football this year I
know that crazy but yes they didn't win
football games they didn't win any of
the big the same point ran like every
day every year no doubt about it I mean
hard team the biggest problem for the
Bucs was the time period of when their
defense was just absolutely 7 it's seven
weeks of the worst offense the end right
so that was really the big issue but I
understand Bruce liking this job he came
out and asked about you know said he
would love the Cleveland job and that's
it
I think these are a lot of the same
similarities low expectations right the
quarterbacks they're okay and then
there's some young budding stars there
the old line is not bad in Tampa the D
line is set
you got a Carlton Davis Vernon
Hargreaves you know there's OJ Howard
right exactly right so I think a lot of
the hard stuff is done now they just
need to fill in the little holes and
gaps here and there the other reason I
like that job is there are some jobs
where you're entering and the the the GM
only has one leg I think the Cardinals
are like that too where the next firing
will be the GM not the coach because
they're already in trouble like people
are already asking about
some light so that it's you're kind of
going in like oh I get the next GM and
then we get to build together right all
that stuff yeah let's go to Dirk cutter
new OC for Falcons good what do you
think I like that a lot too and didn't
Mike Mularkey come along with him did
you see I haven't seen he was coming in
I think it's the tight ends coach but I
think that's a great combination I think
it might be you know again a lot of
former head coaches on your staff which
usually is a good thing usually is a
good thing it's gonna be great for Dan
Quinn too cuz he'll just be able to
focus on defense he's ago I got veteran
guys on that side of the right I'll
stick my nose in just when I need to but
I know they're gonna handle their crap
over there and it gets them away from
the basic West Coast bullcrap that
they've had right and you know cutter
what he does offensively I've always
been a fan of it and I am a fan of Mike
Mularkey and what he can do with the run
game it is that combination there
excites me when malarkey was there as
the OC and some of those times you know
that was a michael turner leading their
league in rushing 14 unholy guards and
let's bludgeon you you know so that
could be a really good combination with
their line their running backs and of
course Ryan and the weapons the Eagles
are what inspired me to love coaching
collaboration and not not trying to get
everyone that's in the same system but a
bunch of different systems together yeah
and what you're seeing is the coaching
staffs that really like embrace that
they have the variety and there is that
difference and then you see it on
defense what happened in Dallas this
year Chris Rashard joining your guy mary
Marinelli right and and showing
different looks because what happens if
you don't you end up like the Cigna
Seahawks and you do the same freakin
thing every play right and it's easier
to diagnose yeah but when you get a
little bit of Frank Reich and a little
bit of D Philip oh yeah a little bit of
Doug Peterson yeah there are different
team every week exactly right there's
four there's four or five wrinkles
they've all added to the game plan to
where you go but you need a head coach
that's not afraid of collaboration yes
some people need the freakin credit yeah
Browns hire Freddie kitchen here's my
theory
yeah if the Browns lost Freddie kitchens
there would be a fan revolt yeah if I'm
a fan of the Browns and that Jersey with
all those quarterback names is finally
put to rest because now all I need is a
Mayfield Jersey and all year long from
Hard Knocks to the end you've seen this
special relationship blossom yeah
imitations on the sidelines joking
around about each other it's very rare
when a young quarterback and a coach
truly form that special relationship
that if you brought in anybody else that
it might you know I don't know what
kitchens if he was like I'm not gonna be
the OC but they couldn't risk losing
that and thus they felt maybe a little
obligated to promote well III but I also
felt like his coaching in the last few
weeks was deserved of deserving it I
mean he made the offense his it wasn't
like he just continued what he's like
germ a totally changed their formula of
how they played and it was successful
and obviously Baker Mayfield loved him
and it energized their whole offense I
mean you know Greg you think Greg
Williams is best oh maybe it
disappointed he probably gets it because
this is where like I think your theory
is is really probably spot-on if they
lost Freddie kitchens the Cleveland
would have they would have been pissed
or what I would say even to that Moore
is you bring in let's say let's just say
they bring in a defensive head coach
right and they keep Freddie kitchens as
OC he has another good year he's gonna
go somewhere else and be the head coach
and you're gonna lose them here lose him
this year losing exactly so I think
that's at the end of the day where they
came with it and yeah he brought
toughness to their offense they ran the
ball the play actions and Baker
certainly played better football under
his tutelage I'll say this to three
coaches that that I'm excited because
their press conferences are gonna sound
so much cooler like Vic Fangio has
you've been saying is gonna be like I
don't know what you does don't gonna bow
it's gonna be great Bruce Arians it's
like that Alabama but also like Midwest
and like everything it's everything he's
in Jersey and now we also have Freddie
kitchens yeah verdict is gonna be -
Alabama - Alabama goodness yeah and then
Kliff Kingsbury I don't know you could
literally bark like a dog
and I might think that's Matt Lafleur's
voice I have no idea what Matt Lafleur's
like if Matt Lafleur got up there and
was like hi I'm Matt Lafleur super happy
to be the but the packers coach I'd be
like Dan that's what Matt Lafleur sounds
I have
no idea what he sounds like was he
selling do a Matloff or just I don't
know it's just a normal guy I don't even
know what to say NFC West is hilarious I
mean what do we got I mean Shanahan
McVeigh and Kings riding an old man Pete
up there I mean it's just funny this new
bar I feel like Pete has the most energy
out of all right right Wow Kyle McVeigh
and Kingsbury right gather I know it's
all three all GQ team walking on the
field to shake each other's hands head
coaches its how's your stubble this week
guys
I just think about McVeigh and Shanahan
are like battling and then Kingsbury's
like it's a three-way battle bros for
like let's just kick his ass and then
focus on each Kingsbury
when he was at the quarterback at Texas
Tech cuz we played against each other he
was the quarterback of Texas Tech when
you were the quarterback of Texas yes
he's throwing for like six thousand
yards a season yes I mean Mike Lee we
lost my senior year at Texas Tech
because Michael each went for it out
forth and down every play the whole game
and they beat us this time oh it was
just it drove me crazy I was just can we
stop them one time cuz they couldn't
stop us but we couldn't stop them either
but yeah so Kingsbury like I said he's a
great guy and I've always known he had
this potential once he got into coaching
once I heard he was at Texas A&M and
doing that I was a GU king cliff will
climb the ladder in a hurry but yeah
Texas Tech in the offseason he used to
come down to Austin and you know we'd
seen him at the bar or whatever I'd have
a few drinks and he was I always liked
cliff he's a great guy he would just
come to Austin a lot of people lose
who's gonna be in love it well exactly
so he'd want to like come there try to
hit on our girls what was it like to see
him cuz you're the quarterback of Texas
and the Texas Tech quarterbacks on your
toes all right I mean I guess you know
you're a ballbuster I'm a ballbuster I'm
also I mean I grew up as stillson's son
so I'm never like oh he's on my
territory like I'm just not like that I
mean you know it's just two alphas
though in college yeah but we were cool
I think you know alphas are cool with
each other cuz they recognize alpha said
yeah I don't know there was no I was
confident in myself he was confident
it's so funny and it was just I could
still remember
the drink I think I saw him at the drink
it was called on sick street it was on
the corner that was our spot the drink
and I remember walking in and going like
thim Kingsbury what the hell is he doing
here just the other thing I want to get
Wes Welker was with him - Wow right oh
because he was a slot receiver man Wes
parties yeah so they were cool that
great dudes before we get into your film
notes on all the games and thus helping
us for tomorrow's betting show we were
talking on the set of the show yesterday
which I would recommend everyone go to
youtube we actually on the YouTube show
break down the real matchup of all four
playoff games
so not just mahomes versus luck what's
the real matchup I don't want to give it
away go on YouTube watch the show it's
good and we have a really good story
from Lamar Woodley if you're a Steelers
fan about how he won the Super Bowl
right really cool but I wish I would
have changed my Chargers Patriots
matchup just a little bit but we'll get
into that tomorrow yeah get it said
tomorrow I asked you if you had ever
like did you actually write papers in
college or where they're just like PA or
TAS writing your papers I just always
thought the quarterback could get away
from it and you said that the only paper
that you've ever written was for your
job interview with the Patriots well I
was being funny I mean I've written
papers I'm not that stupid okay okay yes
now now i yeah first of all at Texas
this is where once I got comfortable
Texas it's a huge school the classes are
huge right I mean I didn't go to class
very much once I got kind of in the ring
and once they trusted me and they knew
they didn't have to check on me class I
didn't go so I was very good like my
first year and a half I got straight A's
my freshman year and they're like we're
good we're good Sims you don't - go
check in on him in class that's like me
like I had to hold a certain GPA to get
in a new house right I got it and I was
like okay oh and I would always pick the
classes with the least amount of
football players I was like I know I'm
not going with those guys who never in
trouble all the time I so they can check
on me to see if I'm there you learned
how to gain the system I learned at a
game the system I always found the big
classes to so I could kind of just melt
in there that they knew they would
there's no attendant took rocks for
jocks halo and I got to go play football
that's all
do okay so I would get tutors is what I
was gonna say at the end of the semester
and like cram a whole semester into like
two and a half weeks yeah
but yes I did a scouting report on my
job interview so my first question is
what is a job interview like with the
Patriots so you were going up there for
what position do everything watch the
bill says he wants me to do did you
think you had a leg up because the coach
of the Patriots coached your dad and you
played in the NFL this is after you
retired what the buzz is after so noise
yeah I'm the Tennessee Titans in 2010 my
last year right and that's what I mean
when 2011 came around and I had some
teams call but nobody brought me in
about late September of 2011 I started
texting bill like hey my career might be
done and I'm looking to getting texted
let's say I wasn't gonna like have my
dad call and asked me I'm just not that
type but God normally I did call him you
texted I texted him I got his number and
I texted them hey coach this Kristen's
blah blah I didn't want to call him that
probably more than any emojis no so I
got on his radar there and he respond uh
yeah he did he responded and I just
periodically would check back in hey
coach great job the last week in the
game
hey coach congratulations on the
playoffs is he what kind of a texture is
Bill Belichick just to the point just
like you think he was and then he no
sound ends with a BB always capital B be
just like Anasuya DS it says BB at the
bottom you ever noticed on the hoodies
because in the NFL locker room they
usually put your number on your stuff
right interest to this so you're telling
me that when Belichick texts always BB
yeah so even if he writes yes Peevy it's
gonna be BB at the end right maybe
that's like his tech signature yeah
right okay so you go up there yeah and
what did you expect like an interview or
you know I knew I wasn't getting
handouts okay I knew that and I knew I
wasn't gonna get any like bumping the
job just because I had lived football my
whole life let's use like in the New
England way I was gonna get put down in
the bottom and have to work my way out
and so at one point they put you in a
room yep I'm up in the front office up
there with like the pro personnel people
and they want you to watch film of two
players and then
a scouting report right Anthony let me
see Spencer yep no you know who was it
was Jabal sheered okay and damn I'm
gonna blank out you know what why I
thought it was Anthony Spencer because I
pro player compared Jabal sheered to
anthony spencer pretty accurate I know
they like that right
um wait hold on a second who was the
damn other guy that I panned these were
guys in college yes they were guys in
college it was two guys and the other
guy all hit me but yeah I to sit there
and you watch to blood sugar watch a
game two games and then right just a you
know two three paragraph report on what
that player was strengths weaknesses and
then sum it up all at the end did you
write in cursive yes did they like do
they comment no nobody commented okay
and then so you watched it and you think
you were pretty spot-on I thought I was
pretty good yes I did do you think
that's the reason that the Patriots
gotcha ball sheared uh no I don't know I
think I think he was already on their
radar um but I think it was just more of
a test to see where I was at football
wise you know they test you to see like
can we have him dabble in the front
office if he is coaching could he handle
that all those things and I think that
was just part of the process for them
was it nerve-racking of course I mean
being there it is nerve-wracking as you
would say walking in the door you're
like I'm being watched
and they're just not the type that makes
you feel comfortable if it wasn't for
Nancy and New England whoa Nancy was the
only thing that hadn't brought him a
smile to my face on a daily basis that a
code word
Nancy is no Nancy is like the secretary
of the front office okay Nancy is her
name
there's nothing I like more I'm learning
about a new car that's my girl right
there now Nancy I don't want to put an
age on her but she's plus 60 I would say
at this point right so she's somewhere
there she is she might bring in cookies
got a little a little Boston edge about
her that I loved you know me being a guy
from Jersey she wasn't afraid to throw
some jabs out there take a jab at your
and what was she in charge uh basically
just getting guys into flying that are
gonna be in the draft the free agents
that I got to come in and make sure we
pick them up at the airport she kind of
man doll down you're just exactly right
she was the lady and if I needed to get
away from the crazy
I always would walk in her office and
we'd have a laugh and a giggle that what
she call you how me she called you
Christopher
probably yeah I love when old people
call you Chris yeah that's Christopher
yes yeah Nancy's the best though I mean
truly I still think about her all the
time
really yeah I do just because Center
Christmas card Jesus she's she's my
buddy all right let's get in the film
notebook all right what I'm gonna try
and do with the film notebook is I'm
gonna try and focus she's +60 I just
gotta be right around there I want to
focus on the teams that are still alive
yeah but I also think oh you know what
before we do that there's still three
jobs opening yes Jets Miami Cincinnati
right you hearing anything you feeling
anything you guessin anything the Jets
I do here Matt rule is he lay there yes
yes from Temple to Baylor to New York
yeah holy crap I think he's and play
there I still think rule Matt rule has
really been more of a college guy played
linebacker at Penn State he's from up
here in the New York area but really uh
had a year or maybe two years under Tom
Coughlin's with the Giants I'm not
exactly sure there it's right around
that range one two three years somewhere
but you know really what I think people
give him the most credit for is what he
did a temple I mean he gave them to ten
when were seasons in a row they'd never
done that yes so Robbie Anderson status
it's a I think a tough hard-nosed coach
who understands the total scope of
everything about football can kind of
dabble on both sides and bring a
toughness and to your football team that
that is what I know Adam GaSe I still
think is there and play for the gym
that's really all I know I don't know
about the Mike McCarthy thing I haven't
heard anything substantial about it
sounds like Aarthi put out like an
ultimatum I'm only going to the gym it
does seem that way
Miami Miami no idea but higher the
there's a lot of great options out there
I mean there's great options okay I mean
who you got a list I do I've got a list
and now Chris Simms official coaching
list that other people probably aren't
mentioning okay so first of all the guy
that took over when they fired Philbin
didn't camp yeah what he would be
towards the top of the list for me you
wanted
about bringing toughness and detail to
your organization he'd be the guy okay
and even though he's not a quarterback
whisperer there's lots of good o'seas
out there like a Todd Monken or a Zack
Taylor or my man Nathaniel Hackett who
made a Blake bortles offense number six
in football are you kidding me if Nate
Hackett doesn't get a job as an OC
somewhere people are effing crazy
well hire him as the Sims and left
co-host OC so you got to talk about him
how about Brian Flores you were talking
about trying to hi I don't know why that
evaporated so quickly and I had heard
substantial that he was very high on
people's lists well maybe maybe they're
waiting because he's still in the
playoff maybe they are exactly right but
he would be another guy you want to talk
about bringing toughness and detail to
your organizes the top of the list Chris
you're a shard we know about him I would
think about Don wink Martindale okay
wink is just all wink is is Bruce Arians
of defense that's who he is for people
that don't know Don Martin Dale is the
defensive coordinator for the Ravens
right now the Dolphins are really crazy
if they don't call Mike Munchak I don't
know what to say there but Mike Munchak
to me with Josh McDaniels would be like
up there with the top guys of the list
and I know Josh is out of it and he
doesn't want to do it but Munchak
certainly would be in that conversation
so there's a lot of different routes you
could maybe use an interesting job right
it's not that sexy right no it's not
that they don't have depth really
anywhere they don't have the quarterback
of the future yeah they're their wide
receiver first-round pick Devante Parker
really hasn't kind of worked out that
much no I know I don't know what's going
on with Kenyan Drake the offensive line
I'm a serious injury got a lot of money
and some defensive players that I don't
think are gonna stick around that much
longer yeah not a lot going on in Miami
no it's it that in the Bengals job are
not very yeah what do you think happens
the bad news I would say the same thing
like no money on huge accident I mean
that that would be one of the dumbest
things in the history of American sports
advanced Joseph being there too but I'm
still betting on it I mean because
they're the Bengals if that happens I
don't even know what else to say I
really don't
it's I'm telling you guys not every
team's trying to win the Super Bowl so a
lot of teams are just trying to sell
tickets you know my my man rich ba Satya
our good Raiders again he's a special
specialty in Jersey City I get that you
don't have to be a quarterback whisperer
to have a
coaching job okay you know they can hire
other offensive coordinators learn to
manage a football game
I think call this out on those things
sure exactly right so to me it's those
type of guys have an especially look at
in Cincinnati because it's not the
sexiest job you do have to deal with
this family yes and they've been a
little bit renegade ish for the last few
years they need to change their yeah
right
holy crate holy crap glad you had a list
I didn't even prepare you for that
alright film notebook I'm gonna focus on
the teams that are advancing yeah but at
the same point like my notes were
focusing on that by me you know though
they were but then also putting the
other team to rest so I'm gonna start
off with Colts and we're gonna do
chronological towards Tennessee and what
you saw yeah first thing that you really
wanted the spotlight was the
Indianapolis offensive line coach googs
goose who is this guy and and and how
much credit does he deserve for this
young offensive line because I feel like
the the national media is giving a lot
of credit to the players right like I
feel like they go that Indianapolis
offensive lines great let's all Cheers
quit Nelson yeah it can't all be cold no
no no the players are great and you know
to get the players there Chris Ballard
deserves that credit first of all you
know just with Quentin Nelson and the
right tackle Braden Smith but Dave to
Gil dig the gilma dig ilmo or never it I
can't even say it to get I don't I don't
know either he took over for Dante scar
Nekia New England when Dante whenever
sabbatical right so he very well
regarded very well regarded well was he
one of the guys that that Josh brought
there I you know I thought it was a
peeper flu I know I'm not sure about I
don't know for sure I don't know for
sure but this is what I'll tell you
about what they do running games well
thought out
they never waste running plays they
don't run into stupid looks or do
anything like that pass protection
phenomenal man-to-man pass protection
not just let's slide and do this yeah
they have you bring five they figure out
how to pick all five up with their five
offensive linemen they don't waste the
back it's little things I look at like
that and then little diverse things
within the running game and I go that
was a really good way to run that play
against that front there
give that credit to the offensive line
coach oh yeah he's the one that's going
to at the end of the day the coach is
good he's really the one that's gonna go
to Frank Reich and a really smart
organization as I've told you with New
England and scar Nekia scar Nekia is
gonna go to Josh McDaniels and go hey
there's this defensive tackle on the
other team that I noticed is really bad
at putting his weight on his left side
sure that or I think these six run plays
are what we want to do against this
front this week with their talent and
Josh would go OK and he'd start to build
his name around the size around exactly
right and I think that's the same thing
that Frank Reich would do but yes I
think it's a very well it's talented but
it's very well coached as well I'm a
firm believer that mike tyson's of lyon
coaches becoming head coaches in this
league because i think he was the most
famous one for a while yes and it didn't
work and that offense went to being like
super explosive to kind of hang out also
he was just like not a great press
conference coach because it was like
food goo Goo's were going to be not mike
tyson kick my ass yeah please do ok I'd
like to see that I could see how
impressed you were with the Colts
offensive line throughout your notes
yeah writing things like why blitz them
luck is clicking even the tipped
interception that want it was gonna be a
touchdown if it don't get to right I
could see how impressed you were but you
did spotlight one possible weak link
yeah glue in ski yeah and you think from
your notes I can tell that when Indy
faces Kansas City yeah they might put
Chris Jones right over glue in ski what
did you see against Houston yeah I mean
just if there's a weak link of the group
and it is Google win ski he can you know
he could have problems with JJ Watt last
week or clowny when he got over them and
I would just think again when they get
into obvious situations and they don't
have to worry about oh we have to put
Chris Jones - the strength of the
formation here because they want to run
to the store whatever and they can just
go we know we're getting to the
quarterback I would expect third and
long right anything like third and six
plus I would expect to see Chris Jones
over globe in ski what numbers kolinsky
do you know 64 all right so when you're
watching the game yeah go is Chris Jones
over 64 it's a good thing to watch
certainly I only just double-check that
to make sure I'm right about that and I
am okay
so that's one that's one that very
interest right because what what Kansas
City should do off of that is find ways
to to make sure he stays singled up
right in those situations don't let the
center come over there and help going
ski out to TT know them if you do four
man rushes you're gonna have to find
different little alignments that's gonna
stress the center from not letting him
help out and double-team a Chris Jones
I'm gonna put Houston arrest yeah their
defense still doing too much still
taking too many risks and then on
offense you wrote they really just waste
plays all the time but the note that
really caught my attention you said was
Watson really needs to get off his first
read fast yeah because the future of
that team is him right so what do you
seeing from DeSean well I mean that guy
that was since Deshawn had the early
season struggles right and then got it
straightened out I would say this was
his worst game of the year since that
point he was off seeing the field
getting off our receivers yes there was
too many times where first guys that
opened I mean he's not open he's not
coming up and get off it let's go to the
next guy how many times for him is his
first read DeAndre a lot of the times
what do they do against yawns well they
didn't do anything special
they played their you know cover three
press bail for the most part and they
got those big corners but they what they
did to to take away some of the hitches
and back shoulders is they would fly
somebody out there underneath him a time
like a cover three where they came over
to he was hurt too
yes but Watson yeah but that was yeah it
just didn't throw the ball great hey
think about stepping up in the pocky
member we had like the tight end going
across and he lost like he missed a few
of those type of throws where he's just
like damn he isn't missed a throw like
that and ten weeks even the the throw in
the end zone at DeAndre how exactly and
I don't think he saw Marcus hunt
who's the size of the building were Lynn
right now who had dropped out right to
they had an eight late a three-man rush
and I do that to the last second he was
throwing it and I think even oh gosh the
biggest onehans there let me try to go
and he missed it so that was my point he
did not see the feel well he didn't
throw it that well and he certainly was
on first reads too much and to the point
of wasting place you just that's I just
you just can't do it
you you can't have six you can't have a
seven-man protection and two men going
out on a pass route when there's seven
guys in coverage and make it seven on to
just that's a wasted play if there's two
deep safeties and they're playing
coverage and you know it's coverage you
got to go to a play that's for that
coverage or run the ball that's where
some base plays that's on Billy O'Brian
and the offense for designing it that
way that's where I say they waste plays
or they run the ball to the right and
I'm gonna go there's nine guys over
there we're gonna run it just cuz we
called that yeah that's wasting plays
that's what I mean by that is that
Watson development it could be to get up
there and go I'm gonna change they could
be it could be part of the development
where they just don't feel comfortable
calling a ton of multiple plays in the
huddle type of thing a lot of different
things that I don't know the answers to
but I just know they waste plays all
right the other side Colts defense cuz
this is gonna be very interesting
they're facing Patrick mahomes yeah you
wrote the Colts they're a hard team to
run against they fly around team speed I
think we know about that yeah awesome
big good big guys at the front I speed
in the back but then you started to kind
of blast the Colts defense and I really
wasn't ready for it
but mainly saying that if you're gonna
beat the Colts defense you need to
spread them out and you need to throw it
and I'm reading that going Holmes does
that yeah and then you wrote this I
don't think they faced a top passing
offense all year and it sounds like you
stopped your notes went to NFL Jesus and
looked at their schedule and then went
was the Giants the best pass offense
they faced all year do you really
believe that I do
I managed as far as like just I'm gonna
pull them up right now yeah go ahead
talent receivers system you know I know
Eli is you know Eli at this point right
so I'm just gonna read them go ahead
Cincinnati this is when they're healthy
that was a pretty good office Washington
no Philadelphia not at that time
Houston not really not really no
Patriots sure okay that would be that
was early in the year - Jets Bills
Raiders negative negative negative
Jacksonville Tennessee Miami negative
negative negative
Jacksonville Houston Dallas negative
negative negative
New York ten
see right and New York does a little of
everything it has at least some talent
that can scare you and they don't even
have Odell for that exactly right yeah
so let up twice listen I'll self Scout
self here I really thought the way to
beat the Colts was to take advantage of
some of their under sized defensive
fronts at times and run the ball but
what happens is what about the Texans
made you realize this because what made
me realize it was all the movement and
speed they have up front it's hard to
sort it out all the time as an offensive
line right like oh I'm blocking the guy
in front of me and I got to do this but
wait he's slanting all the way over to
another gap and oh wait now this guys
coming to my gap but I got to block him
and it's too hard to sort out in real
time at times and because of that and
their athletic up front and those two
middle linebackers they kind of win with
chaos in the run game they always have
eight people by the line of scrimmage
because it's that D ad that Seattle
Dallas type defense right so even if
there's a hole then they got eight guys
in the line of scrimmage and then hey
the linebacker Leonard he's really fast
and he fills that hole really quick like
yeah like a Ryan shazier or somebody
like that right to where you go oh well
they had him there but damn their team
speed got him in time and as I just sat
there to watch more and more in the
second half Houston started to spread
them out I said this is the way to do it
they have no top-tier cover guys I've
been wrong about my evaluations they
have no corners that can play man-to-man
really did you ever argue the opposite
well I argued that I thought some of the
I'm saying in a few weeks ago when I was
saying I think you should run the ball
right at them more I think I thought
they were getting off free and easy
because of that plus you have not
talented secondary and young linebackers
who at times will mess up little things
within their coverages and yeah I think
looking at a Kansas City Chiefs team who
does that and running is not necessarily
their mo right yeah that yeah I would
say that would be what I would do
against the Colts added to the fact that
I don't think there's really a top-tier
pass rusher on that cold steel on a lot
of good don't get me wrong
but not a know there's not one guy that
can wreck again exactly right
also Mike Mitchell's now out
right how big of a deal was that just
from like it was he popping a lot in the
Houston game oh not poppin he's just
like he's at that point of his career
where he's good he does his job the
great declines of stations in the NFL is
why I know like when him and then TJ
Ward's of the world that are like they
just he's a top guy and then all of a
sudden he doesn't exist in position it's
like running back it's running back it's
just there's so many high-impact
collisions for guys like Derwin James
yeah I hear you I hear he's a bigger
human than those guys though so I get
done now I'm gonna sit ah--this eyes
your notes into my brain cool I get done
reading your notes about Colts Texans
and I go about the Colts the offense is
gonna have to put up 42 points in this
game maybe more something in that range
because I got done your defensive notes
and I went man a zone team that's all
about creating chaos up front against a
team like the Chiefs who are gonna
spread you out and it's a way and the
Colts are not that great of an away team
my question for you would be how do you
think the Chiefs offensive line will
handle all of the movement I mean in
pass Pro I have no doubts they can do
that cheese are a good old line they are
they're good they could be good at the
run too if they just were a little more
patient with it but I do think they'll
be able to pass protect and yes there's
no there's no elite Ness
to the secondary of the Colts and
there's no elite as schematically either
they're just sound and this is what we
do and we're gonna go from there and
yeah that will be something I will
certainly be interested to see how that
plays out how do you feel about the
Colts offense against the Chiefs defense
save for tomorrow yeah that's right it's
at honestly similar to what I just said
for the other side yeah yeah yeah it's
gonna be interesting there because yeah
I mean a crowd will play it definitely
more of a factor in this game for this
Colts old line all right let's move on
to the right Dallas and Seattle and most
of the notes here are Dallas most of
your notes for Seattle were this it's so
basic this is so boring
what an awful game plan what are they
doing yeah that's what it felt like to
read yourself on them yeah I mean to in
a nutshell yes I mean that's what they
want to do they wanted to make it that
way it wasn't
they wouldn't you know this is the way
they've played all year run the ball
pound the rock pound the rock rustle
make a few plays when we get some
man-to-man and let it go and throw a
bomb down the field whatever it may be
yes the the pass game is uninspiring and
to all those out there who also want to
just go like you know they ran it too
much I get it maybe they did run at four
or five too many times but if they threw
it too much they would have had no
chance they would have had no chance
don't be fooled by the last Drive of the
game where they went down real quick and
Dallas changed the way they were playing
and they played different prevent
defenses they could not block the Dallas
front not even definitely not in the
pass game they could barely do it in the
run game which they're pretty good at
Wow yeah
all right now Dallas your notes were
very similar you're you were so taken
aback at how elementary Dallas made
their offense yeah then at one point you
wrote you're not gonna run crossers
against Seattle you thought their
offense was way too simple and it gave
me a lot of fear yeah
it that but you know what's weird about
it it was too simple I think they
thought they were just gonna go over
there and overpower the Seattle Seahawks
why would you ever think that you
shouldn't coach more but instead just to
rely on some yeah no I exactly right and
what happened with Seattle said you know
we're not really scared of all those
weapons on Dallas like as long as we
know a little Mary Cooper run go routes
over our head we don't really care about
the rest of you so they played Seattle
played a little bit more man than they
usually do because I think they were
going we're not gonna let this run game
and Pete Carroll was on their butts all
week about stopping the run stop the run
stop the run and they took a few chances
that maybe they wouldn't have in the
regular season and past coverage but yes
yeah I didn't see them start doing
interesting concepts to like the third
quarter when they went down what was it
for 2010 game changed I said we're the
way the [ __ ] is this formation been the
first three quarters
we need another Sims quote right about
cuz it reminds me of the Eagles - you
don't have to just start coaching when
shits going bad right you can coach the
whole game
exactly right and thalis was like oh no
now we're gonna have interesting
concepts yeah see it's like you got to
throw something out all for for being
like this
is what we're good at let's do it and
we're really good at it but you have to
throw a few sprinkles here and there
just to make the defense think the pyres
in the field and the coordinator on the
other side of the field when he's going
Dan the last time they got in this
personnel set they ran that formation
and I wasn't expecting it so I can't
call the defense I want it now because
they do run this formation this week and
I haven't seen them do it and now I'm a
little stress so that that would be my
point there Amari [ __ ] up the screen
early oh my gosh
probably gonna be a walk in touch down I
don't know what he did he could have
gone inside where the screen with the
offensive line was building but he went
outside gotta stay on the numbers gotta
stay on the sidewalk that's what you
would say in the NFL stay on the
sidewalk the sidewalk is where the
numbers are there or the linemen are
gonna come out and clear it out to where
you go inside and go up the sidewalk but
he panicked and saw some color flash and
he went oh no and he ran outside and ran
into the defenders great yeah now yeah
using your notes to look ahead to Dallas
Rams you wrote Looney and Williams so
this is like whoever's playing left
guard yes laughs garden center loonies
the center loonies the center yeah so
pretty much you said that you could see
the Chiefs putting Chris Jones over glue
in ski you're like Erin Donald is gonna
live over the left garden center in this
game no doubt I mean against still a
weak link in obvious situations yes
they're gonna live there those are the
you know and now I don't want to play
great they played okay yeah I don't want
to say there are bad players Connor
Williams is gonna be a good starting
garza LaFell he's a rookie exactly right
and well described earlier he's a sick
of your play and but Joe Looney is like
he's a kind of a career journeyman right
but yes I would think that the Rams
watch that and go man when we get them
in a few situations where we know we can
put Donald there and be okay they're
gonna do their best to make sure he's
matched up with Connor Williams or Joe
Looney dak with pressure and his face is
scary too yeah yeah because he is prone
to do some some bad thing he is the
other thing that you said you wrote in
your notes then you told me beforehand
Shaun McVeigh with the week off and what
they probably did about scouting
Alice already right you kind of in the
middle of your notes was like oh I just
had a thought
yeah what did you think well I just I
sat there and I thought wait okay wait
you know I just I don't even know why I
went down this wormhole but I just
thought man okay rams you're playing
dallas how is that gonna match up as I
was just watching the film and then I
said wait who did the Rams have to
prepare for this week
you know because you got to prepare for
three teams you know they knew they
weren't gonna we play they're the two
seed we're gonna play the same they
weren't gonna play Philadelphia so they
didn't they can wipe that away right but
they've already played Seattle twice who
could have came in the day so they don't
even really need to study up on film
because I've already done it good but
they got plenty another term in Chicago
right and they've already faced Chicago
five weeks ago they play they already
have preliminary game plan stuff they're
exactly right
I would think two to three days were
spent on the Dallas Cowboys just in case
just in case because you just got to
play that card and it just me being in
New England I know that was the same
approach we had there as well yeah I
would think in a way you think the Rams
have already had a few days of preparing
for yeah scares me a little bit does
scare me a little bit definitely um but
yeah that was just something that came
to my other thing we have talked about
those big those runs by Zeke you know
damn those are huge oh yeah when they
crash for the inside run and he bounced
right and I wrote like you know I don't
have pity for you when your corner is
your edge setter like it's like I don't
have pity for you when you get sacked
because you had a tight end blocking
Cleveland right I don't have pity for
you and Anthony bars covering Robert
wood 70 yards downfield same type of
thing it's our duty yeah to show that
they have been exactly right exactly
right
you also wrote though damn the Cowboys
never put a game away no no they live on
crushing two-point losses gosh I mean
it's crazy you look at the game and you
go they're dominating the game and then
you look at the scoreboard flashes and
you go they're losing six to three what
I mean it's insane so there were there
were three things in this game that
scared me in my Monday prediction that
the Cowboys upset will be good the three
things one was the Connor Williams
versus Donald thing yeah - was that the
rams studied a lot in the off week that
scared the crap out of me but the other
thing was a compliment for the cowboy
defense you wrote men the Cowboys have
team speed and they're aggressive and
when they diagnose something they're
gonna kill you and then you wrote so you
got to do misdirection Shaun McVeigh is
Johnny misdirection is Shawn
misdirection yeah Shawn McMissile and I
just read that and I went they're gonna
use the over pursuit of these
linebackers and they're gonna be chasing
jet sweeps one way and counters the
other way and and the rams are gonna do
fake screen fake screen bubble screen
like if the Cowboys are so aggressive
and that's their nature this could end
up being really bad yeah I mean cuz
they're gonna go they're gonna watch the
film and go we can kill these guards we
can destroy these cards let's blow up
the B gap yeah and then the Rams are
gonna go please blow up these guards
that that's what I read that last I hear
you and hey don't jump that you know if
we were if I had a chance to watch her
in my whole bedroom if I had a chance to
watch the Rams I would also probably
have written down things to go this
could be an issue for the Cowboys like
we know that the kid there's a lot of
areas the Cowboys match up with the Rams
too but we were watching the Cowboys yes
those things scare me and McVeigh I
would think his number one thing would
be finding ways to take away the
aggression of the Dallas Cowboys defense
and slow down the speed of their
football team you know just like your
Doug Peterson do I know we'll talk about
in a second but you know middle screens
to the tight end wide receiver screen
running back screen that's what he did
to the Bears so now they're rushing
upfield and they're gone oh damn the
screen went by me 4:30 am i right to say
there's two ways to attack a defense
with athletes there's either max protect
or misdirection miss yes I was to feel
like the two things that you can do yes
and I don't like me max protect no I
don't like mats max protects almost it's
almost like what you said Houston did
yeah where it's like we're gonna have
two receivers that's done you got to
make an aggressive defense think and
give them window dressing and then yes
get Aaron Donald to run up feel right to
then use that leg exactly right you
gotta you got to do those type of things
to that that type of football team I
read your notes and I go we have a real
coaching mismatch in this game I really
I felt that I went
Dallas offense and defense is up against
it with Sean McVeigh and Wade Phillips
it's gonna be interesting it's like it
sucks because I feel like both of my my
games like already I'm like I'm going
opposite I mean you know mine I also
think I would think the Cowboys can run
on the Rams still though yes just so you
know I do and I don't think the Rams you
know what a ton of man-to-man with
Marcus Peters to keep Talib either I
think yeah but as you said yeah who are
they gonna be afraid of yeah I know I
know
who are you afraid of Blake Carlin but
they've kind of changed so we'll see
you're right I know I know
yep I still can I tell you what the key
to the game is in my mind that I'll say
this again on tomorrow yeah the key to
the game is gonna be is Jared Goff
feeling confident or as Jared Goff
pooping his pants because if he's
confident because if Dallas is getting
after him and he's scared
I don't know me well then I would tell
you the key to the game is really Sean
McVeigh and he better find ways to make
golf confident right and that's what you
do though you throw those screens and
things like that I was always talking
about like a basketball player that gets
free throws
seven points a lot though yeah all right
I think so damn I know right Wow betting
is hard or the betting is hard all right
let's go to chargers Baltimore so this
was the sunday game I'm gonna focus
let's put Baltimore to rest okay
you said that man Baltimore's wide
receivers are so slow it's something
they have to address in the offseason
which is so funny because they went out
last offseason and got Crabtree yeah and
got Snead and got John Brown and John
Brown and Snead were not slow before
no let's need we haven't really seen
Snead in two years cuz he was suspended
by the same in the NFL wasn't utilized
what is he utilized but no he's
definitely lost this step I don't know
what happened I don't know if there's I
know he did have a leg injury at some
point but no just he's lost it and John
Brown ain't scaring anybody either it's
just the way it is I don't know either
what to say I feel like ever since John
Brown you know pulled his hamstring for
the seventh time in Arizona he never
regained his explosion just sucks cuz he
had an all time Nick yeah and you know
early in the year when he was fresh and
everything was good he still looked like
oh yeah you guys got a little pep in his
step but man
nada the other thing you wrote was Lamar
Jackson is very inaccurate on short
routes yeah he well he was just he was
inaccurate in this game I don't want to
say that always I just meant he was off
target
like the first interception he threw
right it was a slant to the left I can't
remember it might have been really Sneed
there but yeah I mean that type of throw
against that type of defense who's fast
and the windows are small like and play
zone and watch exactly right so the
ball's got to be placing you know he
threw the ball up here high to where the
guy could barely get his hands on it
pops in the air interception yeah I mean
it was not Lamar's best game but he also
did do some really great things at the
end and made a few place to give him a
chance
chargers wise yeah they're deef their d
front whooped that ass whooped that ass
can't believe it and they did and then
you said but it was third and long you
you kind of were like I could I could
tell sometimes when you're like I would
be afraid if I was out there against
this unit because when they put their
team's speed out there and it's the fast
linebackers and Ingram and Bosa with
their ears pinned back I could tell that
you were very impressed with their speed
oh yeah when they go obvious pass
situation and go Ingram Rochelle Bosa
Cucina knew Oh so I mean man that
Rochelle is like a very underrated very
right he's gonna get paid some by
somebody here yes I mean he is like the
ultimate like you know second-tier
defense and huge I will start for
somebody else and be really good yeah
they were phenomenal there and they made
sure one of those I just gotta say this
right off the bat Melvin Ingram oh I was
gonna get to that next okay so I won't
let's do right now you you wrote
originally this may have been the best
game that Melvin Ingram has had right
and then later in your notes you wrote
holy crap this may have been the best
game of any player in the NFL all season
more than an Aaron Donald for sack game
more than a Khalil Matt game or the best
of Fletcher Cox or Chris Jones you
believe that Melvin Ingram against
Baltimore may have had the best
offensive player game all year he was
just off the charts
he owned or Lane
Brown he owned Ronnie Stanley he double
owned Hearst in the middle or Bozeman
when he came in because they benched
Hearst cuz he couldn't block you know
that's what they did they did the same
thing they said oh you're winkling
sitting the left guard Hearst ha
everytime was an obvious passive
situation it was Bosa over him
it was Ingram over him it was a huge
issue in the football game
but regardless Ingram was not going to
be stopped he was a man on a mission and
I yes I am saying at that boldly it was
the best game I saw from anybody in the
front seven all year in football he was
everywhere run game pass game he was
unbelievable and I also give Gus Bradley
the credit too because Gus let him tee
off in the run game by having guys he
the thing I think that change from this
matchup compared to the last matchup is
they didn't make their d-ends worry
about the read option a whole lot
they're playing get the running back we
got safeties that could handle we got
guys that are athletic on the edge and
we'll they'll be there but you crash and
when it was like a second and forward
you thought oh they're gonna run up the
middle with Gus Edwards you know they
get Bosa and Ingram and get wide and
whoever didn't have the tight end on
their side sure they would go right down
the line of scrimmage full speed and
just as the running back was getting the
ball boom he was going to the ground
no no gain from one cause for all those
fumbles yeah well yeah he caused the
fumble recovered the fumble at the end
of the game that's that's a shout-out to
our good buddy Melvin Ingram Alvin
you're not the best friend we know but
you're doing good
Melvin Ingram never had played Jenga
before so that was that was cool to read
yeah I think it gave me a lot of
excitement about the Chargers Patriots
game yeah when you see someone have an
all-time performance how do they
normally follow it up well I think with
this team they're gonna feed off energy
they're gonna continue to go now they're
gonna be playing a different team this
week who are there the first thing
they're gonna do is go yeah like what do
you think Belichick thought when he saw
that Melvin Ingram performance we can't
let $54.99 ruin the game and then the
game plan grows from there that's the
first thing what are we gonna do to
protect Tom okay and let's grow from
there
we
just okay it's my biggest issue with
coaching is that there are some times
where fans can come up with concepts
that NFL coaches don't do so when I read
your Cowboys notes and I had the
Seahawks notes and I go nothing was
specialized all of it was this is what
we do it infuriates me because Gus
Bradley went out there and said I'm
gonna throw everything out the window
it's playoff football
I'm putting seven secondary guys out
there and I'm specializing a game plan
right the it's just it's like it's like
playoff basketball we know who your
weaknesses and we're gonna attack your
weakness every play it's not about what
we do or we're trying to establish you
suck at this and we're gonna put all
know you have a bruise on your arm I'm
gonna put all of my weight on that
bruise and the good coaches do that
right and the other coaches go well we
need to establish the run exactly right
let's screw you're establishing anything
I know it's a matchup game yeah and so
when Belichick goes what do we need to
stop on what do we need to do on offense
prevent these guys okay what do we got
to do when we're on defense well we need
to attack this offensive lineman I don't
know I just makes it makes too much
sense to me I know it drives me crazy
man I don't know what to say either I
mean you're in the same boat with me see
this is what happens when you start to
learn football you start to go down
these guys are dumb sometimes well you
know why because it's the ultimate this
is why I think the Nick Foles
conversation frustrates you so much in
the haves and the have-nots and what I
mean by that is you are one of the haves
you have experience playing you have
experience coaching you have an
understanding of how to watch film i
watch games and I still need to text you
what the hell just happened because I'm
not noticing that they've run the same
run play I just go they're running it to
the left again III can't pick it up that
quickly but with Nick Foles the
have-nots are on an equal playing field
as you sure I do not have any of that
experience but me and you are both
sitting there going I don't know how
Nick Foles is doing this so it for a
weird time we're equal yeah
you have no understanding and I don't
either and then you and me or Johnny at
the bar they can go you were wrong I was
right Nick Foles did it again and you're
like you have no understanding of why
who how what or when right but that
craziness happens yeah and football is
crazy it's one game it's right it's not
a series it's not a perfect truth will
not set you free there's been a lot of
NBA five the Sixers beat the Lakers in
2001 that's right for the first game and
then lost the next four but if it was
the NFL
the Sixers would have been champions I
know but the NFL's the NFL's crazy it is
point flip League crazy so many
variables that play into all of it no
doubt about that
Chargers other side of the ball them on
offense here's where the concerns come
and I went from liking the Chargers at
+4 and a half I know I'm not so much you
are very concerned about the Chargers
pass offense it hasn't been good and
you're like damn is though are the wide
receivers too slow yes you know it's
funny I had this conversation of my dad
during the week because we kind of both
had said the same thing in the last few
weeks we're kind of just like the
Chargers just rivers arms looked at his
arm looks tired
the receivers when you watch them on
film even the last game of the year when
they played the Broncos I watched it I
mean it's just I was just going damn I
mean Benjamin doesn't look as fast
neither Williams look as fast you know I
think I wrote it in there like my
question was like maybe too many deep
routes from the I thought that was
amazing you wrote you wrote in the notes
are they running too many deep routes
and practice which is like when do you
ever think about that
yeah that's attrition it is it's just
it's attrition is the because I just
thought man what is going on here why do
they not look as explosive to me as they
did early in the year when I was really
going like I think this might be the
best wide receiver room and all a
football and now I'm going down they
can't separate from anybody man-to-man
so I just go through things in my mind
through my experience and whatever else
just to go wait could it be that could
it be this because you say they usually
run like a three-level concept so one
guys always going deep yes they're
they're amazing it D
intermediate short and they usually kind
of work the middle of the field for the
most part other than the occasional okay
throw it up to Mike Williams on the
sideline or here and there but they live
in that area for the most part those
levels down the middle all three levels
but the offense has been underwhelming
lately I just don't know any other way
to say it and I am a little concerned
about it I am because you know the
Patriots have a really good secondary
and they have to shut down quarters and
that's where I get concerned with it
added I was thinking right added to one
thing that was exposed on the game film
this week with the Chargers which you
know I knew was gonna be a something
that gets exposed that thank ler exactly
third down Austin hecklers Oh third down
back because he's a good pass catcher
unfortunately according to your notes
not a great pass blocker no and
Baltimore said oh you're gonna keep
Eckler and I'm third down well well
blitz the back every time so he can't
even go out in the route because we
don't want to have to deal with covering
him but let's see if he can block CJ
Mosley when he gets a 12 yard headstart
and runs into him full speed oh no he
can't right so we're gonna tell you that
it was bad and you know volume even
believed that the Patriots purposely get
big linebackers for this reason I don't
believe it I know this this is what I
know this is from like this is this is
from the walls alright so give it to
even the Giants years I just know this
that's part of the reason Bill believes
in big linebackers that because when you
when you want to get and put in your 190
pound third down running back okay well
yeah he might make someplace in the past
game but when we kind of figure out your
protections is he gonna be able to block
Dante had tower the first time he comes
in there full-speed no way and that
becomes an issue for a football team so
yeah that that aspect worries me I you
really have to be cut you have to be
conscious of that this week but if
you're the Chargers maybe Melvin Gordon
might have to play more than anticipated
you might even have to just put some
other fullbacks your running backs in
there to be the third down back at times
if you're really looking to throw the
ball down the field for chunk yardage
because they I promise you are going to
find a way to get their linebacker you
know running full-speed at that small
running back it sounds like you wrote
like the last few defensive coordinators
the Chargers have faced all have a
really good
feel for their offense and then when I
coupled to like no one's gonna have a
better feel than Bill I know the thing
that's screaming out to me and I'm
looking up right now is the under in
this game hmm
because I'm hearing you tell me that the
Chargers offense is getting predictable
yeah and when I know the Patriots have
such good corners in the backend now
that all those concepts aren't going to
work and then I also see that you write
down that the Chargers have amazing team
speed on the defense and I think about
the Patriots offense lately right it's
right that screaming screaming under it
does scream and I just I want to look at
really quick what I'm seeing and right
now the over-under for the game is 47 so
it's a little bit low it's the lowest
over/under of the weekend yeah uh yeah
right now Indy Kansas City is 57 oh yeah
but 47 it's already a little bit low and
it started off at 47 yeah yeah I would
think I'd still probably be thinking
under there I mean there might be the
Sims and left go bet that we don't
actually make but yeah but my friends
make them makes a lot of sense but yeah
I am I'm just saying it's in New England
you go towards the end of the year the
Bengals game also I hold on really quick
yeah yeah this games at 1:05 I know how
[ __ ] up is it to have a West Coast
team in the playoffs like timeout I just
realized I've got just before you go
down this room oh they just did it this
week and they won okay yeah it's still
[ __ ] ah it's so head I am game for the
Chargers it's [ __ ] up - we've been
complaining about this for two years
you're the one that really started to
get me on this like two and a half years
ago they usually sleepwalk through the
first quarter but that's also a regular
season yeah it's a different animal I
get that but it is still I mean no it
did think about what they had to do they
Baltimore fly back to California and now
they're coming back to New England and
they're gonna play at 10 o'clock game
literally all of my bets are changing
this is not good
we're gonna end up with the same bets
again this is what happens every year
but I leave your notes and I go I could
tell you're very impressed with the
Chargers defense and that their speed
hasn't declined but from your notes on
their offense yeah their offense is a
little bit too predictable their wide
receivers are getting slow they have a
problem blocking pass rushing
linebackers on third down
and that they need a healthy Melvin
Gordon this week he'd rested on purpose
today and they got to get him running
they got to get running the ball
they really do that's gonna be a part a
part of the game that they're gonna have
to be patient with that certainly and I
think they will because Anthony Lin is a
ex running backs coach and he's very
good at doing that all right I thought
that was one of the good things they did
in this game is even though they knew
they weren't really running anywhere
they kept running it just they were
gonna go okay we're gonna chew clock up
we're not gonna let you just tee off on
Phillip Rivers in our pass game yeah you
can create some crazy fumble or whatever
it may be before we get to Philadelphia
and Chicago and thus looking at
Philadelphia New Orleans two quotes from
Sean Payton that have come out in the
last while we've been recording one
saying that letting Malcolm Jenkins
leave was a big mistake and I would
agree with that you know Malcolm Jenkins
has played every snap this year it's a
boss you know what hit he doesn't get
enough credit for knocking Brandon cooks
out of the Super Bowl you're right he
really doesn't I was a game change like
I'm an Eagles fan and I celebrate all
the hits of Brian Dawkins knocking the
number one receiver out of the game was
a huge game maybe the biggest hit and
Philadelphia history no what was bigger
bill Chuck Bednarik from thank you no
you're right that does win I mean you
know that's why I'm here to remind you I
mean it's literally him over and be like
I'm not doing those [ __ ] out I thought I
think I knocked his [ __ ] head off
which I would also say if you're a
football fan and you like Sims in love
CO and you haven't seen the original
Longest Yard yeah with now that r.i.p
Burt Reynolds right but not the adam
sandler crap the original it's great it
was it it was the first time my dad
looked at me and was like this is one of
my favorite sports me it's a good one
very good it really is the other quote
from mr. Sean Payton hmm Sean Payton
went into the Saints locker room with
the Lombardi Trophy on top of 225
thousand dollars in cash which would be
the Saints player Super Bowl bonus and
said do y'all want this win three [ __ ]
games I told you that Sean Payton is a
master player motivator he knows exactly
what they want
so the fact that I know that he has the
old Super Bowl trophy in the locker room
and I don't know how he got two hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars of cash
he has it yeah but I'm just saying you
don't go in a chase and go can I hold
225 like you know like there's a there's
a limit on the 80s well I mean there's a
warranty down there still I got a
Morty's down there he might have 230 in
his pocket but he's got to it there's
212 because it's funny like how many
coaches bring out a hurdle and go you're
gonna face a lot of hurdles men or they
put an axe keep chopping men
Sean Payton goes Superbowl a quarter of
a million that's what you're playing for
win yeah it's awesome you you sat back
in your chair and got excited because
you know you got to think of the guy
who's playing making the league minimum
and he's going I'm gonna get like more
than a quarter years of my salary here
if we can just win the next three like
all of it that's what's great about the
NFL playoffs it's where it's different
about all the other sports the NFL yeah
there's guys being paid but there's only
a handful that are being really making
big money MBA you got like eight of the
13 guys have been great they're making
they're making 3.3 million dollars a
month they're really the payoff money is
like what I'm gonna go piss this away
and throw it on the street who cares you
know it's a different this there's a
different manner and demeanor in
football it's you know not to be a jerk
to the other sports because I know they
work hard but it's a more of a
lunch-pail workman's type sport that I
don't think the other sports would be
upset I think they'd look and go you
guys are crazy for doing what you're
right I just don't want to take credit I
know they work hard it's just it's the
human element of sports that when it
gets to the professional level you just
think they're playing for the name on
the front I'm go holy crap there's a
large check that could be motivating
these guys to play and no one talks
about that no one ever goes after the
game and the winner gets a hundred
thousand the loser gets fifty thousand
and it's like so primal I know I can
still remember in Tampa the year after
the Colts won it in 2006 we signed Kato
Jun the linebacker yeah and he had this
amazing like I don't even know what it
was it was a four-door Mercedes that was
like v-27 it had like twenty seven
cylinders and it could fly to the moon
and I was like damn that car is amazing
he looked at me man
that's my Super Bowl money and I was
like oh yeah that's awesome
right it was and is it the same amount
for everybody is it 225 for everybody so
drew brees gets to 25 everybody have you
win every every week is gonna go
incremental right so the wild card
winners last week I think got probably
like I want to say maybe 20,000 right
everybody on the twenty thousand dollar
check when they were in the locker room
Monday now this week it's gonna go up to
like 35 or 40 you know and then the
championship a little more and then the
Super Bowl I think the Super Bowl winner
I want to say gets like 85,000 and the
loser gets like 30-something something
around there so those are huge that's a
huge swing for guys cuz you're playing
an extra game so it's a little bonus
yeah and that's like League mandated
that's League mandated that's not team
by no no it's and of course that's why
NFL owners love to make the playoffs
because you're not cutting Drew Brees in
a million dollar check after the game
either you know in the regular season
he's got to cut Drew Brees is making
thirty million dollar I gotta cut him
two million dollar check actually all
Drew Brees is getting $20,000 for a
wild-card win exactly that's it he's not
getting any more everybody's getting the
same so the owners are killing it in the
playoffs that's why they really love to
get there that's really what gets missed
they don't get paid normal salaries
they're non paid in the playoffs it's
playoff money this is just bonus money
you want it there's a big trophy and 225
and cash to go get it and Drew Brees is
like what's 225 yeah it's nothing I mean
38 million here's like a but if I win
another Super Bowl every time I sign my
autograph I'll get 225,000 they're
sitting there and like they get to do
like speaking engagements first they're
like whatever right the Drew Brees TED
talk if he gets another Super Bowl his
yes his speaking engagements will rise
to another hundred he's already on Oprah
right drew brees invented kids wearing
bulky headphones during a celebration
he deserves a bows deal yeah let's put
Chicago to bed
you really were impressed with true
brisk ease throws the entire game but
you were not impressed with Nagy's
offense and you're kind of now wondering
heading into next season is it creative
yeah I mean which is so funny Sims
because everybody says it all I hear
that's all it's it's all the useless
defensive linemen at the goal line yeah
right which is cool and I give him
credit for that but you know to compare
his offense to what I saw what
Philadelphia didn't that games not
comparable in Philadelphia was on
another level I mean Doug Peterson he he
must be some grinder clutch mother-effer
because he just the bigger the game the
better the game plan gets it's unreal so
many people are continue to go why is
Doug Peters had not talked about as a
great game planner yeah he should be and
you know I don't really know the
specifics of he didn't what was the play
calling status all year long you know a
little bit of Mike grow right I know he
was calling plays at a time I do feel
like Doug Peterson's a lot more active
on the sidelines when he was definitely
calling him right now I think he's
calling them right now and they might
not want to say it it just seems that
way to me
but yeah I mean just to back to the
point yeah Negi I thought dropped the
ball with not running the ball a little
bit more just you got it you got to run
the ball to keep Fletcher Cox and
everybody honest because your your deal
I never had to worry about the run other
than ten times they just said oh sure
whiskey's gonna throw it let's say in
our pass rush lanes and let's play past
events so that was an issue and then
yeah there was just few too many repeat
concepts and there was just a few too
many scenarios where I felt like
Philadelphia really knew what was coming
and one thing you also about the Bears
was fuller was playing too awful shock
definitely yeah just say when you wrote
when you play Al Shean you just gotta be
hitting him the entire time you got to
do your best to not let him get going
he's a get going type of guy cuz he's so
big it really reminds me of basketball
where it's like don't let him get on the
block meet him at the three-point right
and it becomes basketball when you don't
because he'll box yeah he boxes you out
Foles is great at going oh here he comes
out of the break let me just throw it
high in a spot and fuller won't be able
to reach around that big body and knock
the ball out and falls is a master at it
and so was Al Shean yes it's fun to
watch it's really interesting
Foles and Al Shean together it's like a
Jason Kidd or like an ash into an Amar'e
where he just knows where they want the
ball and he just puts it in the right
spot no doubt and it's hurt
Alshon hi Matthews hi there was some
great throws it really is Marshawn
Lattimore a guy that can jam al shot him
with him yeah that's scary to me yeah
Eli Apple yeah yeah no I mean he's not
utilized not as good as Marshawn but
they're gonna get in their face a little
bit I would think it'd not let Alshon
just go oh let me gather my speed up and
get to 15 if you're not Jam and Al Shean
and Earth's you're not playing the
Eagles correct no I mean like Kendricks
told the whole NFL that on Hard Knocks
you're right this for some reason forgot
to do that - yeah because fuller just
doesn't play that way he's a guy that
kind of plays off or when he does bump
he's not a jammer he kind of just
mirrors and the Saints are bumps and
jammers yeah yeah uh Philadelphia yeah
you wrote you have to test Philadelphia
deep and you got to take a shot at Rasul
Douglas yeah look Eagles fans are right
there with you yeah we don't understand
why people aren't testing us I don't get
it either I mean for one you guys are so
aggressive right now I'm playing so good
and and it's just one way to just back
off the aggression not blitzing just
playing around just aggressive it's just
like I mean you guys are playing down
you guys play downhill the whole game it
was like nothing ever made you pause it
just was oh there's the ball let's fly
at it oh they're dropping back or
they're running boom let's go right to
it there was nothing ever to make them
stutter or stop or whatever until they
called some double moves on a bond a
matter he got the game they got him
right and about deal learned I mean he's
got potential to be really really
awesome you wrote down Avante Maddox is
the real deal he's the real deal man I
mean he's got the first thing he got is
tremendous speed tremendous tremendous
so he's never - really cool dreads right
and he's never gonna be really
threatened by the go route right which
is you know why he gets burned - and
he'll learn to balance that out but yeah
technique-wise you know played three
positions I know
overall smarts all of that are pretty
damn good and ever since they've had to
put him on the outside through the
injuries and all that he's just gotten
better and better every week yes he was
dealing with himself in that game that's
what really happens because he almost
picked two balls had the one in the
sideline Jordan Howard
he almost picked it like the first drive
of the game selling me my whole group
chat was hey Avante can you we were
calling him almost of anti Maddux right
we almost lost through the game too yeah
if this is of all the things you wrote
all four games this is the one that I
went home really if the Eagles defense
was healthy all year they'd have a
first-round bye
they were healthy all year if they just
played this style and simplicity and
there you said they just played three
men or three match they played three
match or just normal three zone 3 zone
oh man right and a sprinkled man-to-man
here and there but it couldn't be any
more basic I mean it could not be any
more base and why is it so affect
because you have an awesome front for
who's whoopin the crap out of people
right now you got two middle linebackers
with Hicks back in the lineup that's
very fast they can fly around you got
Malcolm Jenkins who's really smart it's
amazing right but going on back up a
little bit more Malcolm is like you know
he's your version of kam chancellor I
mean that's what he is he's not the
hitter camp Chancellor is but he is that
quarterback on the defense who's
directing traffic run game pass game
he's equally as effective in pass
defense and run defense there's just
there's no weakness to his game that's
where he is awesome yeah and your team
has become phenomenal tacklers I mean no
not all those know receivers right first
play everybody broke a tackle the whole
day that was what I was so impressed
with Rasul Douglas right that's why I
think Eagles fans have always liked
Rasul Douglas is the man Kentucky is
fearless and tackling you're right about
that
and your man Trey Sullivan in the
backend I mean every week he's kind of
guys kind of goddamn his kids got a
little chance or it but this game I mean
I don't know if I was maybe just it all
feels like fool's gold to me like all
these young corners I feel like are now
gonna go to New England to New Orleans
and it's gonna be like Ted Ginn over the
top the fact that it's so simple I don't
think that because I mean they're so
simple and what they're doing I just
don't think they're gonna be overwhelmed
here I don't that's so funny because
when I read it was simple and simple is
easy to diagnose and Sean Payton Drew
Brees will tear it apart
Dallas is simple - how did that work out
for this New Orleans Saints so explain
to me why simple can be better simple
can be good just because when you have
good talent you're never exposing and
that would be do the Eagles have good
talent yeah okay okay they do I mean
when you have a self a Sullivan crew von
LeBlanc Rasul Douglas Avanti Maddox and
I'm like doesn't sound that I know and
you know I'll use a phrase that we've
heard like Kris Ballard and Frank Reich
know just because they're household not
hold household names yet doesn't mean
they're not good players I've heard them
say that you know Trey Sullivan is going
to be a starting safety in the NFL and
have a career labonte Maddox is going to
be a legit man-to-man corner for a long
time you know so they've drafted well
the craven leblanc you heard schwartz
give the credit to the front office for
getting him you know yes he's done a
good job for them and then we'll like we
said with hicks being back healthy
along with Bradham in the middle your d
lines healthier
I mean Brandon Graham I think played one
of his better games of the year in this
football game not that he I don't even
know if he got a sack but he was
disruptive yeah it's just all going in
the right direction for guys you guys
were the better team in the field that's
all I could say and then I did not think
I would be saying that let's wrap up the
Eagles offense with two big nuggets one
this is the most formations concepts for
this team all year and it's frustrating
yeah but it's also exciting right so you
saw stuff that you haven't seen all year
and like what give me examples I mean
just constant mixings of so third and
nine last drive of the game
okay Alshon Jeffery hits the slant route
to your left right they were [ __ ] in
the shotgun I'm sorry Josh that I've
cussed this book that's what happens
when I get excited about playoff
football there in the shotgun he had two
backs next to him back behind him and
Alshon Jeffery was behind him what yeah
I don't remember with the tight end to
the right at the normal tight end
position Reyes went to the motion out to
the left and so what did you think when
you saw that on well I just saw a lot of
you said you want an example and I'm
saying there was little things like that
all game a lot more emotions some
different formations and I do
when yeah I'm like you because I like
the Eagle style a play when they're good
I find it refreshing it's tough it's
tough yeah it's just it's it's fun to
watch exactly just with a little little
sprinkle of coolness there in there
that's all you need it's really what
Andy reads to it in Kansas City we do
what we do but we're gonna do a little
window every veneer every now and then
so maybe Doug Peterson's like you and
college just likes crammin maybe he does
maybe he does but it was a lot of I
thought different concepts different
formations and I thought the same thing
I was going to dip I mean they'd be 13
and 3 if we just played this way the
whole year if we weren't messing up
cover 3 against the Titans on 4th and 15
or you know jumping on a double move
when Kirk Cousins is on his one one-inch
yard line so he could throw a bomb for
80 yards down the field feeling it was
little things like that that kind of
screwed you guys when you wrote Foles is
a [ __ ] giant jaw and that and 4qc
that is not a curse for me Sims wrote it
right you wrote he's an effing giant
he's a giant you know Chicago has a
weird all 22 sideline film it's a little
bit lower - lower exactly right it's the
only one in the NFL that's like this as
soon as it comes on you're like oh we're
in Chicago but you really get to see the
size of him because it's lower and he's
such a big guy and I know I used my
phrase that I always use that size as a
skill yeah we don't talk about that at
the quarterback position you know but
size is a skill because this was a game
I said in my notes Kaleo Mack was a
little more disruptive than I gave him
credit for on TV he was around Nick
Foles a lot Leonard Floyd was a few
times - Folse is just unfazed by it it
just doesn't matter he's so big and it's
like a Big Ben or a cam he's just oh oh
you're cool Mack I can I could see over
you I mean it's probably gonna hurt when
you hit me but okay I'll just I'll be
all relaxed and the clothes and throw it
out there I mean that's how he does it
it's like but it's amazing and yes his
size in this game just jumped out to me
he was not intimidated like most
quarterbacks are when they play the
Bears and they go oh gosh the pockets
collapsing he just didn't care
I'm just realizing
having broken down all four games the
only team that you left seemingly more
confident about was the Eagles yeah all
the other game first time I'm actually
gonna buy in on the Eagles Cowboys but I
mean like Cowboys Chargers and Colts all
three of those games I came away reading
your notes and feeling a little bit less
than flaws right right yeah yeah I know
I know
and flawless that the other teams could
take advantage I liked flaws that are
really tough for the matchups right like
your issues with the Colts or that their
past defense can be attacked and they're
facing Patrick for Holmes the flaws
against the Cowboys war they're too
aggressive on defense and they're too
simple on offense and I'm like they're
playing the freaking rams and then the
Chargers are like their offense is basic
and can be discovered and they're
playing Bill Belichick like all three of
those flaws are epic Sims I know I know
like you flipped all three of my bets
today I'm just admitting to you but the
Eagles are the one team that I got done
reading your notes and go we have a new
advanced offense with a quarterback
that's an effing giant and a defense
that's simplified and get to the
quarterback right where's the flaws I
know
only problem is you gotta play the best
team in football you're just the one
team that has to play the team that's
truly the most well-rounded team in
football I'm gonna now ask for
everything I gotta finish ok I just
gotta finish with this because we got to
talk about what the Bears did and some
of the flaws of their football team
right like nobody has talked about this
first of all I mean if Nick Foles
doesn't throw the one interception in
the end zone and do that so game tape
they did say in the broadcast of the
Bears had 10 on the field for the touch
right they did talk about that also that
you're not yes right right so but I was
just saying Foles if he doesn't done
interception I really think you're gonna
control this game a lot more than but
either way yes I know they set it on the
broadcast I'm saying nobody's talked
about it all week I haven't watched one
TV show on the Dallas Goddard touchdown
the Bears only had 10 on the field they
had no middle safety no it was really
they had no Nickelback McManus who let
up the end of the game he was focused on
the whole game he he did not have a very
good day he messed up the things I'm not
even talking about physically he messed
up some things mentally and did think
you're not supposed to do but on that
play that was nickel defense and he was
not in the on the field and
and 38 Adrienne a MOS he's in the
backend like trying to point out traffic
and he realizes something's wrong but he
can't figure it out
he's like pointing at the corner and
he's talking and he's like and you could
tell there's like wait what's why I have
to go cover this guy over here way this
shouldn't be and he had to go match up
but there was no middle safety and you
guys ran to post that would have run
right into a safety yeah so that was
huge
now the end of the game that went right
options Bren right option two Golden
Tate Nick Falls which I didn't realize
was the exact same play that Matt Ryan
ran with Julio Jones like that's insane
I didn't know it was the exact same
little in a different way but yes still
you run right I run right right throw to
you so I'm gonna pull this up so we can
just talk about this in real time okay
there big guy you were I think in your
notes you said why did they not
double-team Golden Tate they they I
believe they were double teaming him and
McManus messed up so here's the play
just so you see it okay okay so here
here look how low that Cameron right
three receivers you're right right
they're gonna blitz they want to blitz
these two guys right here who
linebackers in the middle right and it
looks like a MOS is over Aguilar yep and
you have McManus and and Dion Busch this
is Oh both over golden tilt and they're
stacked almost at this point yep but
really when you get into the end zone
look you're gonna see Busch is playing
for the inside and then McManus is
playing for the outs but he should be
and he's not yeah he's kind of like he
straight up over his head up and he
should not be he why isn't a most
pushing him I don't know but this is a
common theme of the game where the Bears
defense and I think it's because you
guys did more formations there was a
whole lot of talk before every snap they
weren't sure of their rules and yes so I
think that is the issue with this play
now we'll go to the end zone hey Moses
just stand-in there he's standing there
right now maybe I'm wrong maybe they're
totally messed up and maybe a MOS is
supposed to be here against oops sorry
against um maybe he is supposed to be
covering now Sean that's Aguilar in this
line right
no I'm saying maybe he's supposed to be
here
okay how do I got this messed up oh no I
wasn't sure maybe if either way I don't
know what the hell I'm saying I don't
know I I'm getting curious your main
point is I'm not sure I'm not a hundred
percent sure McManus and then we're
supposed to double-team him here or let
me just get this straight my brain here
and I'll do this live time so anybody
can make fun of me or if oh this is what
I want to say or okay I got it right I
just couldn't figure out what I was
thinking before or was Bush supposed to
be over Aguilar over here and a MOS is
covering the back in the back field
either way
miscommunication either way miss McGee
McGee education misalignment and I
thought I said I think they're trying to
double Golden Tate and McManus should be
playing outside of him so he can't make
the outside breaking great but I'm not a
hundred percent about that so I don't
want to totally blame it yeah either one
either way they were confused it sounds
like the whole game a lot do you feel on
of those can confuse the saints no the
Saints have kind of adopted your guys
motto where they went to just wait
we got a good front for and let's play
simple in the backend they've not been
the same way and that's ever since they
got their defense straightened out
that's basically what they did I'm gonna
ask the Sims and Lefko listeners all the
homies to enjoy something but then also
help me out I have set myself up for a
very awful offseason my constant
badgering of the Saints fans and their
team even though on our podcast we
predicted that they would go to the
Super Bowl not just before the season I
also predicted they'd win the Super Bowl
in week 13 like I did do that yeah sure
but I am public enemy number one and I'm
gonna be honest it's a lot of fun the
attention is great
my mentions are awful and the insults
are coming in high I'm sure so two
things I want you to enjoy if the Eagles
do loose which is a very realistic
possibility enjoy really just go into my
mentions and look at all of the hate
that I'm getting but if any of you have
any ideas to turn it
what's gonna open up Sims it like homie
PR where if you guys give me some ideas
to how to flip it or it's like it's like
if you got into mentions too and we're
like oh no left goes like a huge Saints
fan like if we just like flip it and
confuse them I think we can battle back
but I'm just letting you know that I
have a feeling the Saints are gonna win
the Superbowl and thus the next eight
months of my life are going to be awful
could be trouble especially when I saw
the graphics of the last time they won
the Super Bowl they were a 13 win team
with their three losses coming against
the Buccaneers the cowboy like the same
exact team right and I'm like and we're
getting another Super Bowl so just if
you can help me out great
other than that we're excited to see you
guys in Atlanta again hit us up in the
email Sims and Lefko at gmail.com tell
us who's your name what is your name how
many people are coming and what nights
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday we're
doing a podcast or a show every night
we've already got a ton of people saying
they're gonna be there it's gonna be fun
there's a chance there's gonna be free
drinks I think that chance is about 90%
so we're gonna have a blast it's gonna
be a good time we will talk and ball
having a good time let's wrap it up
betting show tomorrow for Sims peace out
homey centric would say good evening and
the lef koe man says holla holla holla
holla holla you may have changed all my
bets and that's what happened I gotta
think about what I'm gonna do I know for
me I'm tryna think strategy I want to go
against you right I also want to be
right I'm still winning
damn I'll let you guys later man